what institutional problems does the Met
have
so I think what we have found right
across the Met is institutional and
systemic racism sexism and homophobia I
think the culture of discrimination and
Prejudice is very clear it's very
evidenced in the report is very weighty
with the evidence around those three
issues in particular where we have
weighed up you know are there not
everybody in the metropolitan police is
racist definitely not but do they have
racists in their Force yes they do are
there serving police officers and staff
that experience for example misogyny or
race or sexism yes there is is there
systemic problems so for example if
you're black you're 81 more likely to be
in the misconduct system than if your
white that was so much worse than I
thought it was going to be and then
finally let's again take both women or
the black community the fact that we do
such a terrible service to women is in
itself we we under protect protect women
in the community and for black people we
know that they are under protected and
over placed so the use of force for
example from tasers batons handcuffing
you're much more likely to have that
done to you if you're a black person
than a white person so we have found
that right across the organization and
again don't fight it accept it and
change it what does it what does
end-to-end vetting look like that's what
you recommend end to end within the life
their lifetime at the police how much
vetting do people need so I think that I
mean right now even even as we publish
this report there hasn't been a change
across the whole of policing that says
anybody that's got domestic abuse on
their record or anybody that has
indecent exposure isn't automatically
removed from the ability to be a police
officer so I think the thing they should
be of course they should be yes I mean I
think you know they please us if I am
assaulted they have to come and help me
and actually if they do that in their
private life why on Earth would I expect
them to then come and deal with me
effectively it's like the standards that
we need police officers to hold are
above what the rest of us actually have
to hold that's why we give them special
powers what's shocked you I mean I was
shocked by what you were saying about
the fridges for example can you talk me
through that and any other things that
have kind of really jumped out at you
well I think that the the the public
protection teams who are full of people
that work their absolute damnedest they
really are they are sort of
long-suffering hard-working
um but they are so up against it you
know 44 of detectives in public
protection are trainees
they carry case loads of 20 to 30 rapes
which means that's 20 individual women
all men but mainly women who've been
raped how on Earth can you manage a
caseload like that and get them through
to court and then I felt it was just so
symbolic and so tragic that actually
fridges and freezes every time I was in
public protection teams people go well
you know we can't even get decent
fridges and freezers so essentially they
carry rate kits and other specimens the
fridges are so dilapidated and so
crammed that some of them break down and
when they break down essentially those
specimens are no longer usable which
means that that sets back a rape case
and I felt it was not only tragic
it was symbolic of how we treat women as
victims in London and how the Met
allowed that to happen I think is is
pretty Dreadful this has been a met
focused report
should there be a Louise Casey not
necessarily you but should there be a
Louise Casey type review into every
other police force
I actually think the answer to that is
yes because I think that what we have
found there are some things there light
vetting like sort of the cultural issues
particularly around race and around
women I think that they are National
issues I think that some of the
frustrations around the misconduct
system are National so some of the laws
that do need to change they are National
changes that the police Chiefs need and
I do think we need a wholesale change of
public protection particularly for women
I think we all say violence against
women and girls is a priority I then
switch to see what's actually happening
on the ground in relation to that and I
don't think that's good enough it rings
Hollow to me and I think it rings Hollow
nationally so we need this across the
country a proper delve into what's going
on within police forces I think that we
need a route and Branch review of
policing as we move into the 21st
century and that that is one of the sort
of public sector parts of the public
sector that has not been reformed
efficiently and I think that that that's
no excuse for the Met not to get on and
do a significantly better job but I
think there is a challenge there for
police forces nationally okay finally
this expression a few bad apples I mean
is it a few bad apples what's your view
on this it's absolutely not a few bad
apples I think that that is people
Clinging On and clutching at straws what
we have found is systemic problems right
across the Metropolitan Police
81 percent of uh you're much more likely
to be in the misconduct system if you're
black by the tune of 81 if you're a
woman you're much more likely to suffer
at the hands of other police officers as
a female officer one in ten of you is
being sexually assaulted or sexually
harassed that's really really horrific
and the service to londoners
particularly in relation to to women and
to the black community frankly isn't
good enough